now that we've seen the nintendo switch  we have a lot of questions i'm tony in  this game spot news update just might  have some of the answers Eurogamer  reports that the switch tablet is a 6.2  inch screen with a 720p resolution it  also says the street is indeed a  touchscreen with multi-touch capacity  this would be a big step up from the Wii  U and 3ds one touch inputs but it also  raises a question about how touch  controls would work if the tablet is  inserted into the dock Eurogamer  accurately reported on the nintendo  switch before it was revealed so take  this news with as much or as little salt  as you wish we'll learn much more about  the Nintendo switch on January 12 2017  expect to learn about price specs and  the launch lineup during Nintendo's next  presentation stay tuned to gamespot for  all the details and for all the biggest  nintendo news you're already in the  right place  you